we're told to plot these values on a
number line and you see every one of
these values have an absolute value sign
so let's take a little bit of review of
what absolute value even is
absolute
value the way i think about it there's
two ways to think about it the first way
to think about it is how far is
something from zero so let me plot this
negative three here so let me do a
number line this isn't the number line
for our actual answer or to this command
plot these values on a number line this
is i'm just first going to plot the
numbers inside the absolute value sign
and then we're going to take the
absolute value and plot those just like
they're asking us to do so on this
number line if this is zero if we go to
the negative we're going to go to the
left of zero so this is negative one
negative two
negative three
negative three sits right over there so
this is negative 3 right there negative
3 right there the absolute value of
negative 3 is essentially saying how far
are you away from 0 how far is negative
3 from 0
and you say well it's 1 2
3 away from 0. so you'd say that the
absolute value of negative 3 is equal to
positive 3. now that's really the
conceptual way to imagine absolute value
how far are you away from
zero from zero but the easy way to
calculate absolute value signs if you
don't care too much about the concept is
whether it's negative or positive the
absolute value of it's always going to
be positive absolute value of negative 3
is positive 3. absolute value of
positive 3 is still positive 3. so
you're always going to get the positive
version of the number so to speak but
conceptually you're just saying how far
away are you from zero so let's do what
they asked so that first value on this
number line so all of these are absolute
values so they're all going to be
positive values so they're all going to
be greater than zero so let me draw my
number line like this
i could do a straighter number line than
that
let's see well that's a little bit
straighter
and let's say if this is 0 this would be
negative 1 then you'd have 1 2
four
five
six
seven i think that'll do the trick so
this first quantity here i'll do it in
orange the absolute value of negative
three we just figured out that is
positive three so i'll plot it right
over there positive 3
then this next value right here the
absolute value of 7. if we look over
here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
7 is how far away from zero it is seven
away from zero so the absolute value of
seven
absolute value of seven is equal to
seven so you already see the pattern
there if it's negative it just becomes
positive it's already positive it just
equals itself so plotting this value
we'll just place it right over
there so the absolute value of seven is
seven absolute value of negative three
is positive three
let me mark out the or the zero a little
bit better so you see relative to zero
now we have the absolute value of eight
minus twelve the absolute value of eight
minus twelve well first of all let's
figure out what eight minus 12 is so if
you take 12 away from 8 you're at
negative 4. 12 less than 8 is negative 4
and you can do that on the number line
if you don't if this is a little bit
if you don't quite remember how to do
this but if you you know one away from
if you take eight away from eight you're
at zero and you take another one you're
at negative one then a negative two
negative three all the way to negative
four so this is equal to the absolute
value of negative four
if we just plot absolute negative 4 we
go 1 2 3
negative 4
is right over there but if we're taking
its absolute value we're saying how far
is negative 4 from 0 well it's 4 away
from 0 1 2 3 4. so this is equal to
positive 4. so we'll plot it right here
this number line is the answer to this
command up here so the absolute value of
8 minus 12 which is negative 4
is positive 4.
then we have the absolute value of 0
of 0.
so how far is 0 from 0
well it's zero away from zero the
absolute value of zero is zero so you
can just plot it
right
over there and we have one left let me
pick a suitable
color here the absolute value of seven
minus two
the absolute value of seven minus two
well seven minus two is five so this is
the same thing as the absolute value of
five
how far is five away from zero well it's
just five away it's almost you know too
easy that's what makes it confusing if i
were to plot five it's one two three
four five it is one two three four five
spaces from zero so the absolute value
of five is five if you plot it
just like that so conceptually it's how
far you are away from zero but if you
think about it in kind of just very
simple terms
if it's a negative number it becomes a
positive version of it if it's a
positive number already it just equals
itself when you take the absolute value